musicals so oder so leute und ihr habt
schon im titel des videos gesehen dass
sich heute alles um das hier dreht diese
frisur hat mich ungefähr die letzten
eineinhalb jahre meines lebens sehr
beschäftigt als im september 2016 ich
würde glaube ich sagen dass ich nicht
lügen wenn ich sage dass ich im april
oder mai 2015 entschluss gefasst habe so
meine haare zu haben und es hat einfach
so scheiße lang gedauert die wachsen zu
lassen und jetzt sind sie endlich so
langsam ein paar monaten und die sind
wirklich lang herr und abgeheilte tiefe
trauer bei youtube ich sehe mich nicht
mehr dadurch hätte ohne scheiß leute wie
starten die ganze chose heute mit einer
großen abstimmung und zwar habe ich als
ersten link in der beschreibung eines
rock eines stopper gepackt da könnt ihr
abstimmen ob ich mir die haare
abschneiden lassen soll ja nicht womit
ich jetzt nicht sagen will dass ich
meine entscheidung ob die haare abkommen
von eurer entscheidung abhängig mache
aber mich hat das jetzt mal so was leute
über denken und wo hat man die
möglichkeit so viele leute auf einmal zu
befragen wie youtube
genau irgendwo deswegen klick auf den
ersten in der beschreibung und stimmte
ab wenn es juckt wenn es euch nicht
keine ahnung macht etwas anders mit
eurem leben ich durch wird auf jeden
fall fünf dinge vor die mich am meisten
an dieser frisur nerven
vielleicht schaffe ich es wirklich bald
ab was ist eigentlich der obenauf diesem
schuhkarton wisst ihr was wir dekorieren
dass man kurz und motorrad-fan sache nur
haare fallen aus ein alle mädels da
draußen ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich
irgendwo her alle jungs da draußen die
doch nie lange warten
ihr kennt das ziemlich wahrscheinlich
nicht menschen mit langen haaren fallen
wahrscheinlich sogar noch eher die haare
aus als menschen mit kurzen haaren aber
es ist so gestört überlegt euch das gut
bevor ich lange haare wachsen lassen
es dauert nicht nur ein faktor anja
sondern wenn sie so die richtige länge
erreicht haben dann denkt sich der kopf
so ok der sie hat die haare genau sagen
wir haben wollte [ __ ] you jetzt wollen
sie auch soll das heißt nicht dass ich
jetzt die glatze bekomme ich dann meine
herren so ganz normal da oben aber wir
hoffen wirklich aus nach dem duschen
darf ich erst mal zehn minuten lang es
ist keine chance vom kopf ausgefallene
haare war hier von den armen von der
brust von kanal und überall wo die dann
hängen bleiben pflücken
es verlängert die ganze prozedur um
einiges sache nummer 24
sache nummer 2 wie einige von euch
wissen mache ich ja auch noch die sache
mit seiner frisur zu metall geht hat man
genau zwei möglichkeiten erste
möglichkeit man betoniert sich die
scheiße fans bis zum gehtnichtmehr
zehn kilo stahl beton in die haare dass
die jahr halten und selbst dann halten
sich nicht lange oder man geht haben
ganz normalen zopf fehlen und die
pfeiler nur auf 2 minuten raus und dann
so aus so sieht einen scherz oder bei
der stadt peter maria nach 20 minuten 1
1 beim sport ist ein job sehr nervig
weil die haare die garzeit rausfallen
aber gut komme zur sache nummer drei
nämlich in langenhahn anpackt
leute halten ein für ein hipster oder
verein der den trend verpasst hat also
es gibt wirklich leute nicht nur eine
person nicht zwei personen die chance
mehr habe meinen sohn lange haare sind
auch aussah und die leute denken ich
dann wahrscheinlich so dass ich so
unfassbar bescheid wenn das ich so an
der realität vorbei hier dass ich nicht
mitbekommen habe dass diese lange haare
rennen frisur schon seit zwei jahren
wieder vorbei ist ja im großen ganzen
ist das problem einfach dass diese
frisur immer noch so als hipster frisur
gehen leute kommen nicht damit klar wenn
ihr meine frisur hat die bisschen
ungewöhnlich ist heute kommt einfach
nicht damit klar wenn sie etwas
ungewohntes sehen deshalb war so dann
gehts hier oben kopfsache nummer vier
alte leute sind intolerant leute ich hab
eine oma viele von euch haben
wahrscheinlich auch noch oma und ich
sage euch 1 jahr geht man mit seiner
frisur zu eurer oma und hört euch mal an
was sie dazu zu sagen hat wenn meine oma
meine mutter valley hätte mich verstoßen
allein wegen der frisur ist es unfassbar
wie sehr großeltern ungewöhnliche
frisuren hey ich und meine geschwister
macht seinen doktor zu unserer oma was
hält eigentlich von sebastian frisur
meine oma rastet deine richtig aus also
die sagt da nicht so gefällt mir nicht
sondern man merkt richtig wie diese
wirklich emotional mitgenommen ist und
zu sein
das ist echt nicht schön man das ist
echt nicht schön und sache nummer fünf
keine sache die auch gut nervig ist von
zwar wissen wahrscheinlich einige von
euch mal ein bisschen kürzer noch ein
bisschen länger hatten dass je länger
die haare werden es umso länger dauert
die haare abzutrocknen und wenn er so
lange haare ab wie ich hab dir gesehen
die gegen ungefähr so wenn ich die runde
mache gehen die von vorgänger so bis
unters kinn versucht es gleich zu
trocken komplett die einzige
realistische option die man hat ist
einfach sich die haare zu waschen und
dann einfach darauf zu hoffen dass sie
an der luft trocknen bisschen dass hier
irgendwie trocken geföhnt habe vergehen
ungefähr drei jahre überlebenszeit und
zwar jedes einzelne mal holen das ist
auch schon ziemliche schlauch gerade
waren morgens spät aufgestanden ist es
der stunde gerne in der beschreibung mit
dem link up würde mich interessieren wir
sind vom nächsten video wieder biss dann
haut rein macht's gut
ich klicke die kamera aus dem leben
alter 2